encuentra el recíproco de dos enteros
cuatro quintos si queremos encontrar el
recíproco de dos enteros cuatro quintos
primero debemos de pasar este número
mixto a una fracción impropia hagamos
eso entonces tenemos dos enteros
quintos y lo queremos pasar a una
fracción impropia la fracción impropia
seguirá siendo entre 5 pero el numerador
será 5 por 2 más 4 y esto es porque 2 es
lo mismo que 10 quintos o lo que es lo
mismo 2 es lo mismo que 5 por 2 entre 5
vamos a escribirlo en numeradores 2 por
5 4
fíjate que aquí tenemos al 2 porque 2
por 55 es 2 y aquí tenemos a los cuatro
quintos
2 x 5 es 10 4 14
en 35
y ya pasamos este número mixto dos
enteros cuatro quintos a una fracción
impropia catorce quintos
y ahora
ya podemos obtener el recíproco de esta
fracción lo voy a escribir él
sí
pero
y recíproco y para ello solamente
debemos invertir el numerador por el
denominador el numerador por el
denominador es decir nos queda 5
14 años y ya terminamos